well we can speak now to the mayor of uh
london sadiq khan mr khan thank you very
much indeed for being with us
uh this is going to impose quite a lot
of cost on quite a lot of people living
and using london isn't it
well it dresses the twin challenges of
air pollution but also the climate
emergency what we do know is as a
consequence of the toxic care in london
that you can't see
we have more than four thousand
premature deaths a year
we have children who've got permanently
deformed stunted lungs
but also adults with a whole host of
health issues from
asthma
to heart disease from cancer to dementia
and what we do know is that when we
introduce this policy in central london
and led to the toxic air in central
london being reduced by almost 50
percent we want the rest of london to
benefit from that as well
but what do you say to people
hit by the cost of living
hit by record petrol prices who say well
you know this is going to be more than
12 pounds a day for me to go about my
daily business in london
well the good news with the ski we
introduced in 2019 is actually most
people
got a compliant vehicle and those that
didn't chose to walk cycle user public
transport the numbers of people who were
compliant when i first announced the
policy was
and that's been that's increased 87
over the course of the first two years
to help those families who need a
vehicle to move away we have a scrappy
scheme of 61 million pounds and that's
taken 12 000 vehicles off our road so
that's still open for low income
families for those who are disabled for
charities who've got a swap bearer
minibus and this week in the
chancellor's budget we're asking for
more support for him to enable more
people who've got to move away from
polluting vehicles to make the
transition easier
and how many people
do you reckon
both
obviously private use but clearly
business as well actually would be well
advised to change their vehicle
well i think anybody who's got a vehicle
that is a pollutant that's not used as
compliant
should be having a vehicle that is
compliant the good news is
most people who want to come to london
in a vehicle are doing the right thing
so look at heavy vehicles hev lorries
buses and so forth now more than 95
percent are us compliant and by the way
the entire country benefits from these
hev lorries if they're euler's compliant
they turn out less knocks nitrogen oxide
less particulate matter less carbon they
help address the issue of the air
pollution crisis but also address the
issue of the climate emergency as well
and in the days leading up to glasgow
and cop 26 it's really important we show
bold leadership you know the area of
london covered almost 4 million is
double the size of paris eight times the
size of manchester we're showing the
world we're leading the way in london
how much extra money in the short term
do you think this is going to raise
well actually we're hoping that it
doesn't raise any money because people
are user compliant this costs us a huge
amount of money to put the machinery in
place the the cameras
the signage and so forth so it'll be
some time before we'd see any net
additional revenues to uh tfl the
evidence from the central and the new
less was actually more and more vehicles
became compliant as i said they were
from 39 being compliant 87 compliant so
the monies we raised when done we don't
want to raise money because more and
more people chose to either walk cycle
use public transport to have a compliant
vehicle and what are the statistics on
the improvement of air quality in what
has been the smaller ules and will be in
the bigger one
so what we saw is the number of schools
in areas where the air was unlawful went
from 458 schools to 11 schools that
shows schools improving as their quality
reduced
air quality improvements led to toxic
emissions reducing the amount of
nitrogen oxide reduced by 44
the amount of particulate matter reduced
by 27
the carbon emissions reduced by six
percent so a good example of good
policies from politicians leading to
benefits and we're hoping over the
course of the next year we see a hundred
kilotons reduction of carbon emissions
that's about 60 000 cars being taken off
our roads and we're hoping to see a 30
reduction in nitrogen dark side across
all of london and by the way
you know toxic here doesn't doesn't
respect boundaries of cities so other
people outside of london will benefit
from our policies too
we
had the case of the
the girl who died living on the north
circular and her family uh were able to
take to take the government effectively
to court i mean are you worried that
they're going to be a lot more cases
like this i mean effectively you're
having to do this because you will
become
the mayor of london or the
greater london authority will become
basically
likely to be sued on a large scale
we should be able to count rosamund
whose ella's mom is here
what the coroner found in the inquest
was air pollution was a material
contribution to ella's death
this pollution this toxic air is caused
by us
a large proportion of the toxicity comes
from transport and that's why i feel so
passionately about this is the poorest
londoners least likely to own a car who
suffer their worst consequences and we
should be held to account
and um
how do you feel about the approaching
cop 26 the government's laid out its
position are you satisfied uh as as a
labour politician with that uh
particular set of proposals
well as a londoner as a human being i
want to see our government leading the
way i think it's really important that
boris johnson our prime minister is seem
to be leading the way and does lead the
way i think alex sharma has worked
incredibly hard over the last few weeks
and months we're going to see in glasgow
whether the hard work pays off it's
really important as the host country we
show a leadership we need to see
during glasgow us agreeing on how we
have policies that reduces uh greenhouse
emissions how we clean up the air
pollution problems around the world the
global north
has got to walk the walk the reality is
the global south can't do this by
themselves one of the reasons why i was
incredibly proud to be made sure of c40
these are global cities across the globe
uh across the planet who represent more
than 700 million people
across from paris to new york from
dhaka
to los angeles showing how we can make a
transformative uh change if paris set
out what needs to be done glasgow has
got to set out how we do it this is the
last real chance we've got to make a big
difference it's really important we
seize that opportunity and the prime
minister's got a big responsibility i
wish him well i'll be in glasgow working
with him uh showing leadership but also
persuading colleagues across the globe
why they've got to
step up as well finally we're just
getting some breaking news insulate uh
britain are out again today they've been
disrupting the roads uh they would say
they have the same ultimate goal as you
uh what do you think of their behavior
no i think we may agree on the ends but
i disagree completely with their their
means
of course we've got to make sure that we
instantly insulate our homes better that
leads to more energy efficiency less
carbon emissions but also reduces the
build we pay as well and it creates jobs
as virtuous circle i'm lobbying the
government to have a retrofit revolution
to deal with this issue the way to
persuade the government to do that isn't
by the tax it's used by insulator
britain they're driving people away from
this really important cause i'd ask them
to stop